English is the most widely spoken
language on the planet research
estimates that there are upwards of 1.5
billion English speakers worldwide
that's billion with a B more than 18 of
the entire global population
but how did English become the most
widely spoken language in the world and
why are there so many different kinds of
englishes well the first kind of answers
the second there are so many different
world englishes because there are just
so many English speakers with diverse
cultural and societal influences
impacting their language use I'm
speaking American English because I was
born raised and educated in the United
States but there are over 160 different
englishes around the world and as more
people learn English more varieties of
English are developing it's even the
language of the air and of the sea
Aviation English and sea speak in fact
English language education is considered
so crucial that 138 countries require
English to be taught as part of the
mandatory Core Curriculum that's 70 of
the countries in the world and another
40 offered as an optional course of
study so in total at least 91 percent of
countries have some sort of formal
English language curriculum but the real
question is why English and why not some
other language let's jump in I'm Dr
Erica brazowsky and this is other words
[Music]
other words
English wasn't always that popular in
fact French used to be the go-to
language for diplomacy in business when
communicating between entities that
didn't share the same language otherwise
known as a lingua Franca now lingua
Franca literally means language of the
Franks which at the time of its creation
really referred to all Western Europeans
not just the people who live in what is
now France it derives its name from the
original lingua Franca capital L capital
F which developed in the Mediterranean
Basin through borrowing from several
languages and was used for trade and
diplomacy in that area from the 11th to
18th centuries capitalized lingafranca
as actually a pidgin language but that's
a topic for another day back to French
after the Norman Conquest in the 11th
century William the Conqueror installed
french-speaking Nobles to rule England
who quickly replaced English with French
in all domains of power from the courts
of law to the church although the
peasants still spoke English the
aristocracy maintained French as their
preferred language for the next few
hundred years and by the 14th century
French was the most widely spoken
language in Europe by the 17th century
France was the leading land power in
Europe and French was well established
as the language of prestige replacing
Latin as the language of diplomacy in
international relations so why aren't we
all speaking French right now well one
we aren't all diplomats but even if we
were there was a huge Global power ship
in the 20th century
the world wars English was already
predominant in the technology and
Innovation sectors thanks to the
Industrial Revolution but after the
first world war the negotiated treaties
were written not just in French but also
English which was a big deal giving
English space in the diplomacy scene
after World War II France was frankly no
longer a dominant power English the de
facto language of a new major economic
Powerhouse of the United States became
the language of the economy and Money
Talks put simply English is the most
popular language in the world because of
money and power
and American English is particularly
popular because of Pop Culture
influences imported all over the world
including TV music food and Cinema so
that answers our first question but what
about the second one why are there so
many different varieties of English well
first there is no set Standard English
unlike French who's standard on
everything from usage and vocabulary to
grammar and even the dictionary is
enforced by the academy Francais English
does not have any such authoritative
governing body determining correctness
which means we get a lot of variation
between English is spoken all around the
world and they're all proper and
authentic englishes beyond that it's
really the same reason why anyone talks
differently from anyone else there are
cultural social historical political and
geographical factors that contribute to
the way we all speak within the United
States we see English as based on
cultural heritage like African-American
English Chicano English and cajun
English or on region like Pittsburg is
or Appalachian English and if you're
from England you know the difference
between Yorkshire and Lancashire English
even though the counties are only two
and a half hours apart many Global
englishes are influenced by local
languages for example Singapore English
or Singlish which is based on British
English because of that Colonial history
includes elements such as discourse
particles and Loan words from other
local languages including Malay Hawken
and tubble the same is true with
Nigerian English where there weren't
words in British English that expressed
certain cultural Concepts that were then
borrowed from native languages of the
region linguists have attempted to
organize the various englishes into a
model the most famous is barrage katra's
three Circle Paradigm where countries
are labeled Inner Circle Outer Circle
and expanding Circle
the Inner Circle contains the countries
whose primary language is English the
Outer Circle contains countries where
English is used as an official language
or a second language typically countries
that were colonized by the Inner Circle
and the expanding circle is where
English is widely used but learned as a
foreign language in other words
everywhere else This lends A
hierarchical vibe but if you've been
following along you know that no one
language is better than any other there
are multiple scenarios about what could
happen next maybe all of our englishes
will converge because we're all so much
more interconnected or oppositely in a
Tower of Babel moment they'll become so
different as to be mutually
unintelligible unlikely
more likely if English doesn't Remain
the most widely spoken it's because
another economic Powerhouse sways the
tide of language popularity in a
different direction but for now English
is the foremost World language in an
increasingly globalized world the most
important and exciting part about all
these different englishes is the fact
that if you speak English you can
communicate with literally a billion
more people than you otherwise could and
if you can speak multiple languages well
then you're ahead of the game replacing
Latin as the language of diplomacy and
international relations
now lingua Franca literal Franca English
wasn't always the popular back to French